can you talk about writing a script week
one versus at the last week what that's
like stresses involve the highs the lows
well many writers they get very stressed
all the way through there is a sense
where you recognize that the process is
the process it's it's not meant to be
smooth but you learn to say I'm in
process it's okay I know this scene
doesn't work it's okay for it not to
work today I'm going to think about this
I'm going to go back and you know rework
and of course toward the end many times
you're doing small things like doing
word changes saying this word has more
resonance than that word it's a better
choice so you're rewriting all the way
through and there is a point when you
feel good and then you get it evaluated
or you get somebody else to read it I
say oh my that is just wonderful or
here's eight notes but don't do more and
I've worked on many scripts where I've
said don't do any more than this because
this is working and don't futz with that
don't don't play around and say let's
say there's a point you have to realize
let it go now maybe in the process as
actors come in there's going to be
changes or a director but there is a
point you say you know I think I've done
the best I can and I think it works
you